mmm something else we're talking about
great story bloomberg new energy finance
team and it deals about massive shifts
that we are seeing right now in the
power markets according to the team
we're talking about trillions of dollars
flooding into the renewable energy boom
which means the way you get electricity
it could ostensibly change forever one
of the main highlights no surprise solar
power is getting cheaper and cheaper we
have a chart that shows how solar power
is going to overshadow existing coal and
gas plants yeah solar is going to loan
make up for more than a third of new
power capacity around the world and the
biggest slow revolution will take place
on rooftops there's a number attached
here in terms of price tag 2.2 trillion
dollars will be invested in rooftops by
2040 my question here is that for a
place like New York or the Metro New
York area you need sufficient sunlight
and I'm not sure that we get that right
now climate change has made it so that
new york is rainier and cloudier than it
used to be and you don't get enough
sunlight and you're not going to be able
to get that the solar power of roofs to
really do very much well they're also
too many trees that cover them
absolutely and according to the data
that we got from our Bloomberg team it's
still not happening fast enough so at
some point even if you get this solar
powered and it's on roof tops of
buildings is it going to make a
difference are we playing catch-up
because of all of the damage that's been
done so far yeah it's a really good
question people also talk about natural
gas as a fuel that can act as a bridge
fuel between fossil fuels like coal and
renewable energy and according to
bloomberg new energy finance few
countries outside the US will replace
coal plants with natural gas even in the
US wind will be cheaper than building
new gas plants in eight years and
utility-scale solar going back to that
rooftop solar plan panels they will be
cheaper than new gas plants in 21 years
so perhaps the moment has passed but
speaking of data points the finance team
did say 2.2 trillion go into roost
rooftops by 2040 yeah exactly so we'll
see how it all plays out certainly this
is good news for any company that is
looking to capitalize on this movement I
believe we'll be following this sector
is